[Music]
the Apollo space flight program lasted
from 1961 to 1972. Apollo 11 was Neil
Armstrong's famous First Step Apollo 17
was the last manned mission to the Moon
in all 20 Apollo flights were planned
but Apollo 18 19 and 20 were canceled
but in 2007 a retired astronaut blew the
whistle and claimed Apollo 18 19-20 did
happen but they were highly classified
he knows this because he was the
commander of Apollo 20. he said the
reason these missions were kept secret
is because of what they found on the
moon well not just what they found also
who they found
foreign
the primary goal of the Apollo space
flight program was to land the first man
on the moon this was achieved on July
20th 1969 when Neil Armstrong famously
said it's one small step for man
Chester that was Apollo 11. Apollo 12
also landed on the moon successfully
Apollo 13 had to abort after Tom Hanks
famously said Houston we have a problem
but Apollo 14 15 16 and Apollo 17 all
made it to the Moon
but here's where things get weird the
Apollo missions made all kinds of
scientific discoveries that experts
still studied today but despite the
success of these missions Apollo 18
19-20 were canceled due to budget cuts
and lack of public interest but ever
since then there's been a story floating
around that those flights actually
happened but they did so as part of a
top secret black budget program
eventually we would get confirmation of
this in 2007 a YouTube user with the
handle retired AFB posted a video that
set the internet on fire it was a short
clip that showed the interior of an
Apollo spacecraft first we see an orange
porthole looking out into space
Skeptics were quick to jump on this film
as a hoax but if we compare it to actual
known photographs of apollocraft it's a
match the next shot is of a control
panel and this too matches other Apollo
missions what stands out is the flag and
the mission patch these are hard to make
out in the early videos but we'll see
them in detail later on the flag is a
combination of the American and Soviet
Flags the patch shows Apollo 20 the name
of the mission at the bottom of the
patch are the names of the astronauts
Snyder lanoff and Rutledge soon after
releasing the video retired AFB admitted
he was William Rutledge of the United
States Air Force and Mission commander
of Apollo 20 which flew in 1976 the
middle of the patch shows two spacecraft
with ropes or cables around it a
submarine no a staging no a submarine
you said that already yeah well I
couldn't come up with a third one and
comedy comes in threes oh you think this
is comedy yeah Bite Me Anyway the
submarine is actually the purpose of the
mission Apollo 15 went to the moon in
1971 and it had taken a lot of pictures
and what was of particular interest
officially titled Apollo image
as15p9630 it shows a swath of lunar
landscape on The Far Side of the Moon
but if we zoom into this area we have a
hill right that's the image that's
currently available to the public but
originally it was this
but NASA also has this
that is Apollo 20's Mission identify and
if possible breach the two mile long
spaceship that crashed on the moon 1.5
billion years ago
[Music]
over time Commander Rutledge released
more photos and videos online he also
released excerpts from his journal and
gave more background on the mission to
the Moon in 1971 the Soviet Academy of
Sciences contacted American president
Richard Nixon with a proposal the
Russians had images of the ship taken
from the surface they also had images of
what looked like a city but they didn't
have the technology to visit the site
but the Americans did after the success
of the Apollo soyuz which was the first
U.S USSR joint space mission the Soviets
proposed another mission Cosmonaut
Alexei leonov commander of the soyuz
would accompany two American astronauts
to the alien crash site you say that
again what alien crash night yeah it's
liking music sweet sweet music so leonov
and Rutledge were joined by Leona Snyder
who would serve as the pilot then on
August 16 1976 in the dead of night a
Saturn V rocket took to the sky and
embarked on the most important and most
secret space mission in history
10 9 ignition sequence size
six five four three two one at the end
of the countdown just after Ground
Control calls zero there's a moment that
seems to go on for hours at that moment
years Flash before your eyes and play
like a movie in Reverse your thoughts
turn to friends to family to hope the
capsule shaking like crazy and you're
aware of the rocket engines swelling
like a tidal wave but there is absolute
peace the mind quiets there is no fear
fear would come soon enough
foreign
[Music]
liftoff is called and the rocket begins
to float people think you shoot off the
pan like a bullet but in truth you hover
just for a second not even a heartbeat
you float but the next second the next
second begins a physical ordeal that
will last eight and a half minutes
foreign
of a building pushes against your chest
making every inhale a battle of life and
death it's not uncommon for someone to
pass out during these eight and a half
minutes though when that happens we'd
never tell
after the crushing journey through the
atmosphere you go from three G's to
weightless in an instant it's like it's
like a tether suddenly snaps and then
you float it's not uncommon for someone
to vomit at this point but again we
never tell I look down at the Earth and
white clouds swirl over blue oceans I
look at the land 125 miles down and get
the sense that someone somewhere is
looking up I take a moment to catch my
breath and smile those eight and a half
minutes roaring through the Earth's
atmosphere that was the easy part
three days later on August 19th at about
10 30 in the morning the Apollo 20 crew
entered lunar orbit then the crew was
informed of a secondary objective for
this Mission track down and find out
what happened to Apollo 19. whoa what
well the Russians had much better
information about the alien crash site
which is why the Americans agreed to a
joint Mission the United States sent
Apollo 19 to explore the wreckage a few
months earlier but the mission failed
only the Apollo 19 crew and the most
senior people at Nasa knew about this
Mission the launch and transit to the
Moon went fine but Ground Control lost
radio contact when Apollo 19 got to The
Far Side of the Moon they hadn't been
heard from since Rutledge and his crew
were instructed to check a specific
storage compartment in the landing
module this compartment typically held
tools and containers for bringing back
moon rocks and soil samples oh but not
this time but not this time this time
the storage compartment had guns
foreign
my name is Carl wolf and I was a
Precision Electronics photographic
repairman with a top secret crypto
clearance
in the United States Air Force I was
stationed at Langley Air Force Base in
Virginia
in 1965
um in mid-1965 I was loaned to the lunar
orbiter project at Nasa on Langley field
they had problems with a piece of
electronic equipment that was
bottlenecking their production of
photographs
I went to the facility and when I walked
into the facility there were scientists
from all over the world I was stunned
actually to see people at a NASA project
from all over the world it didn't make
any sense to me initially
I was taken into the laboratory where
the equipment was malfunctioning a
Airman second class was in the dark room
at that time I was also an Airman second
class I was interested how the Hope
process functioned how the data got from
the lunar orbiter to the laboratory
asked the young man if he described the
process to me he did about 30 minutes
into the process he said to me
in a very distressed way
by the way we've discovered a base on
the back side of the moon
and then he proceeded to put photographs
down in front of me and clearly in these
photographs were structures
mushroom-shaped buildings spherical
buildings and Towers
I worked there for three more days and I
remember going home and naively thinking
I can't wait to hear about this on the
evening news
and here it is more than 30 years later
and I hope we hear about it tonight and
I will testify under oath before
Congress that what I'm saying is the
truth
Rutledge and layanov sat in silence as
the moon rover closed the distance
between the landing site and the alien
ship Rutledge felt that the silence was
inspired by part wonder and part fear
the hull of the ship first appeared over
the moon Horizon looking like another
Hill but as they drove closer the men's
chin slowly raised higher and higher
when they were finally in the shadow of
the craft it was hard to tell how big it
really was unsure of the ground
underneath they decided to park the
Rover about 800 feet from the craft and
travel the rest of the way on foot
religion laying off chatted amiably on
the walk but the closer they got to the
ship the quieter they got it was massive
and awe-inspiring the ship was over 300
feet high the length of the football
field and as high as a 30-story building
and just as wide the length of the ship
seemed to go on forever they knew the
ship was two miles long but that's just
a number until you're right on top of it
the first thing we noticed was how old
the ship was having been on the moon for
over a billion years it almost looked
like part of the landscape the hull of
the vessel was coated in Moon dust the
powder that turned everything here gray
another indication of the ship's age was
that it was pockmarked with ancient
meteor impacts
Salient ship has been here since before
the Pyramid of Giza was built before the
Sumerian civilization emerged but I
started to become dizzy realizing the
ship has been here since before the
first dinosaurs walked the Earth
everything about this Mission stretched
the limits of the human mind it was too
big to comprehend too old to comprehend
here I was walking on the surface of the
Moon having traveled here in a rocket
the Pinnacle of human technological
achievement and yet in the shadow of
this ancient Relic that somehow made its
way here from a distant star a thousand
Millennia ago I felt like little more
than a caveman compared to this
technology our species was still rubbing
six together to make fire at that moment
I felt very very small they had no
trouble entering the ship it looked like
the area was cleared by heavy equipment
though there were no machines in sight
the exterior of the ship was covered
with impacts strange shapes and markings
but the anterior walls were perfectly
smooth before going further Rutledge and
layanov took a quick minute to confirm
they still had radio contact to Leona in
orbit and to ground control on Earth
they did over many centuries lunar soil
filled the floor of the ship they
weren't stepping on metal about 60 feet
in patterns in the lunar dust indicated
that some type of fluid had flowed there
at one time maybe a hydraulic leak they
couldn't be sure over the radio they
were instructed to grab samples but all
they can get was a little dirt from the
ground NASA wanted pieces of the ship's
wall or equipment for analysis but their
Hammers and chisels couldn't even
scratch it much less chip off a piece
but the walls did have a strange
property gravity a gravitational field
could be felt coming from the walls and
now that they focused on it gravity on
the ground felt slightly stronger on the
inside of the ship Rutledge speculated
that this would make Interstellar travel
much easier we take gravity for granted
on Earth but it is very much a key to
our survival when you human bodies
without gravity experiences
physiological stress almost instantly
without gravity bone and muscle mass
quickly wither so daily vigorous
exercise is needed when the human heart
doesn't have to contend with gravity
blood pressure goes out of balance
sustaining injuries without gravity is
dangerous because blood doesn't flow it
pools its face any type of internal
injury is almost certainly fatal our
balance depends on gravity the fluid in
our ears that tells us which way is up
Suddenly has no concept above digestion
is more difficult without gravity
helping food move through the body the
problems are endless Engineers on Earth
had many proposals on how to solve the
gravity problem space stations could one
day be built like Wagon Wheels like in
the movie 2001 but there was no
structure like that here Gravity was
coming from the ship itself somehow
Rutledge and leonoff followed a path
that led them to an upper floor down a
wide Hall and into a large chamber they
finally saw something that even though
they expected it still surprised them
Signs of Life
in the darkness the walls seemed to move
in the larger part of the ship the walls
were perfectly smooth but here Moonlight
was being scattered in all directions by
a rough surface when Rutledge and
landoff got closer they saw what
appeared to be plants and vegetation
dried purple Vines a hundred feet tall
line the walls even though there was no
sound in space rutledge's mind couldn't
help but fill the Silence with the
rustling of a breeze through trees on a
calm day beneath the plants were trays
that were collecting a thick yellow
liquid upon closer inspection it was
gold and phosphorescent finally
something could be recovered from the
alien ship the men took about two liters
what they called Golden Tears Golden
Tears huh that sounds ominous for a
minute Rutledge had forgotten that they
were broadcasting from lunar orbit Leona
broke in
we've got Houston on the line
imagine too early
seen the move too the room continues for
a long way I think I see light up ahead
we could probably reach it in an hour
we want you to protect
lamb and get those
[Applause]
Roger that control returning to Len
Rutledge and laying off retrace their
steps out of the ship and headed back to
the lunar rover about halfway through
their walk Lay It Off grabbed Rutledge
by the arm and pointed to the ground
about 50 feet from the path will
oil do you see this what where
two lines side by side how do you say
the same distance apart parallel yes do
you see
I do what is that when they got close
enough they realized what the lines were
tracks in the dust recent tracks made by
Aluna Rover but not their lunar rover
uh Rover team to Orbiter you there Leona
I'm here well what's up
you better get Houston back on the horn
why what is it
tell them
till then we found Apollo 19.
[Music]
after a few hours of sleep the Apollo 20
crew debated with ground control over
whether to explore the Apollo 19 module
Rutledge Snyder and leonov wanted to
check for survivors or at least find out
what happened Ground Control was against
it they argued that whatever happened to
Apollo 19 could easily happen to Apollo
20.
don't think it's a good idea to follow
the same path that led Apollo 19 to
failure we don't know if this is an
equipment issue or if there's something
dangerous at the land inside
understood control but their families
deserve to know what happened
their families don't know they're here
as far as they know their loved ones
died in a training accident
control could Apollo 19 have any
material to help us complete our mission
negative Apollo 19 has no additional
resource
control is there a chance even a small
chance that we find living astronauts
we're all sure there's no chance of
finding anyone alive one final question
control
does control agree that we leave no
astronaut behind
Ground Control agrees
we're going
Roger that Apollo 20 perceived with
caution good luck will control out
the black silhouette of Apollo 19's
lunar module loomed on the horizon it
was still connected to its first stage
booster a sign that the astronauts
hadn't left Rutledge had a glimmer of
hope that the crew of Apollo 19 could be
alive somewhere in the alien ship but
the truth is he expected to find three
corpses the Apollo 19 land was probably
now a high-tech tomb with final messages
for families taped to the control panel
which is what he would have done they
parked the Rover and Rutledge felt a
wave of adrenaline wash over him the
hatched the module was slightly open
this means it wasn't pressurized if the
astronauts were here they weren't alive
Rutledge and leonov walked cautiously
around the module and inspected it for
damage it looked like it had landed hard
the nozzle skirt was partially buried
and folded then Rutledge kicked
something in the lunar dust he bent down
and brushed the gray soil away it was a
white glove with red fingertips Apollo
20s colors were white and black the
glove belonged to someone from Apollo
19. brother was trying not to panic he
looked around for laying off but he
didn't see him laying off was already up
the ladder an opening match
[Applause]
there is something yes but
what our body
it is a body but uh well
it is not a human
[Music]
Rutledge and leonov stood in silence for
at least two minutes taking in what they
saw unsure of how to proceed inside the
Apollo 19 lunar module buckled tightly
to a folding metal table was an alien
body
that it appeared to be a humanoid female
she was naked but her body was covered
in a waxy substance Rutledge thought it
could be a highly Advanced type of
pressure suit the alien female was about
five and a half feet tall she had two
arms and two legs like a human but she
had six fingers on each hand on her
forehead was a tattoo or design that
resembled markings that they saw inside
the ship her face was decorated with a
device that consisted of stalks fixed to
her eyelids cheeks and mouth
near the table was an overturned
container that had a little bit of the
golden tear substance dripping out of it
Rutledge closed the hatch and started to
pressurize the module if they were going
to examine the body they needed to
remove their helmets
hold on remove the helmets are they
crazy well they needed to see and
specifically hear what they were doing
this is a terrible idea what if she
implants an alien egg in them or
something yeah I don't think oh what if
the alien gets some of the astronauts
DNA and then and it comes to Earth it
makes an astronaut clone which replaces
the real astronaut but the astronaut's a
hero so the Clone the Clone becomes a
senator and then and then after a few
years the alien clone becomes president
of the United States
then we get an alien clone in the White
House
actually how much worse can I get well
once the cabin was pressurized Rutledge
and laying off gingerly removed their
helmets Rutledge expected the air to
smell like Decay but there was a
distinct Aroma of almonds yeah I don't
know why but that makes it even scarier
I agree Leona was a biochemist before
becoming an astronaut so she would be
helpful but she was an orbit on the
other side of the moon so Rutledge and
leonov had to do the best they could
until she came back into range Rutledge
felt for a pulse but he couldn't detect
one he put a stethoscope on her chest it
couldn't hear a heartbeat but he heard
what he thought sounded like a whooshing
sound some kind of liquid moving through
her body they determined the alien was
neither alive nor dead she was in some
kind of suspended animation They removed
the stalks from her face and Rutledge
thought she had a slight smile from then
on they called her Mona Lisa Rutledge
gently examined the alien while laying
off filmed and took photographs
[Music]
foreign
ER was back in range she radioed down
but this time on a private channel uh
Snyder to over will you okay
oh we're okay Leona we we found
something unexpected in the Apollo 19
lamb no crew but uh
we know Houston is back online we can
see everything
you want to patch me through
not yet well
um
what is it
Ground Control nose
they know they know what
about what you found in Apollo 19 slim
they already know
no
but we also found a bloody glove and I'm
pretty sure it belongs to Jim Reynolds
we need to do they know about that too
they know all of it
I don't understand how they would Well
Control wants you to bring the alien
woman back to your module what why
they uh
Leona what what is it
they want us to bring her home
[Music]
the Apollo 20 urban legend has become
one of my favorites and the more I learn
about it the more I like it when YouTube
user retired AFB AKA Commander William
Rutledge posted his Apollo 20 videos the
internet exploded the videos look so
good but is it real absolutely no damn
it there are a few articles out there
that debunk the videos practically frame
by frame but there's no reason to go
through the trouble someone openly
admitted to creating them the videos
were created by French artists Thierry
speth as part of a science fiction film
Project he was working on he used a
combination of practical effects and 3D
to create videos the two videos that got
the most attention were the ones of the
control panel and of the alien woman
because they look really good but he has
a lot of other videos connected to this
project and they don't look as amazing
now even though aspath freely admitted
to creating the legend somehow it took
nine years for anyone to bother talking
to him about it credit goes to Chad
Baxter for finally interviewing speth in
2016 and I'm I'll link to that interview
below the story you heard today is
basically a mashup of a few versions of
the Apollo 20 urban legend floating
around the internet mixed in with the
novel speth wrote that tells the entire
story I'll link this Beth's novel below
but before you spend money on it be
warned despite writing the book in
English speth doesn't speak it very well
so as far as stories go it's clunky but
still it's entertaining it's Beth's
version of the story the alien woman
wakes up during the procedure and knocks
Rutledge unconscious and those Golden
Tears they collected the yellow goo yeah
in the story it has medicinal properties
lanov has cancer with only a few months
to live he drinks the goo and it cures
him by the way Alexi lanoff is one of
the most famous cosmonauts in history so
speth changed his name in the novel also
Rutledge and Snyder they end up having
an affair in space then they get married
and they also drink the yellow goo which
makes them age more slowly what about
the bloody glove right remember the
plants inside the ship yeah well they
ate the Apollo 19 crew the glove was all
that was left
wow wow yeah there's a lot going on in
that novel as I said it's clunky despite
speth admitting to creating this you'll
find interviews with the quote unquote
real William Rutledge and those
interviews have expanded the lore but
you know
a French
well a lot of people thought that and
that's why it's so weird that nobody
bothered to talk to him but about
halfway through the interview with Chad
Baxter speth holds up a mask of the
alien woman and it's the same alien for
sure 100 go back and freeze frame it's
absolutely the same alien if you want to
see exactly how speth made the video
look so good I'll link to an article
called Apollo 20 deconstructed so how is
a story like this believed by so many
people for so many years I think the
answer is easy it's the American
government's fault yeah it's always the
government's fault you don't even know
what I'm gonna say it doesn't matter
it's still the government sport there
really were three more Apollo missions
planned and they really were canceled
due to lack of funding and lack of
public interest that is one of the
biggest tragedies in human history
Apollo 17 was extremely successful space
exploration should have been a top
priority for the United States and the
Soviet Union instead they made their top
priority war in Vietnam in today's money
that war would cost a trillion dollars
in 2022 NASA's budget was 22 billion
dollars that's a budget reduction of 90
percent since the 1970s yet the United
States Department of Defense budget was
722 billion dollars not including black
budget right so let's call it a trillion
that's really why the Apollo program
ended America beat Russia to the Moon
that was the mission not exploration not
research not science not the betterment
of all mankind it was petty competition
that's why I'm rooting for the Chinese
to keep launching missions to the Moon I
hope they find more helium-3 and other
valuable resources because that's the
only way my country gets back to
focusing on Space if you can't count on
American Ingenuity at least you can
count on good old American Greed and the
United States better not wait too long
because if China has only a fraction of
the success of the Apollo program it
won't be long before all speaking
Mandarin
[Music]
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor like
subscribe comment share I know it's
annoying to hear me ask that but it
really helps the channel and like most
topics we cover on this channel today's
topic was recommended by you if there's
a story you'd like to see or learn more
about go to the yfiles.com tips a
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible if it wasn't for
our patreon members there would be no wi
files and if you'd like to support the
channel consider becoming a member on
patreon you can support the channel for
as little as three dollars a month or
grab something from the Wi-Fi store did
you raise the prices on the hecklefish
coffee mugs yet not yet I forgot what
this isn't a charity I'm trying to run a
business over here that's gonna do it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated you're running
a business I mean really
[Music]
thank you